all right let's jump into this first
story from timcast.com
president biden tests positive for
kovitt reporting mild symptoms
i don't i don't know how much i should
really care about this story i don't
know how much i should believe this
story but the big story i guess is the
rampant speculation immediately
president harris started trending once
again as it often does whenever biden is
sick with something
and then people started speculating as
to what's really going to happen and so
my favorite conspiracy theory i know
it's a conspiracy theory is that biden
or i'm sorry kamala harris will step
down
and take a prestigious job to fight
climate change or something biden will
then appoint to vp newsome
then biden will get 25th amendmented
where it's like his brain doesn't work
and he's incapable of doing the job
right now it's already happening well
yeah i mean he accidentally claimed he
had cancer or he does one of the two
either way it's bad and then
he chooses stacey abrams to be vp that's
like the apocalyptic scenario yes oh
well i don't okay well first off let's
say this cancer's horrible i mean
god forbid i really hope he doesn't have
cancer that would be awful and kovad we
wish him well we hope he feels better
but he does have dementia and we really
need to know i mean he needs to you were
doing so good
i was like cancer's bad yes covet's bad
oh no but he probably hasn't i'm sorry
he's not doing well he's not doing good
and um but i will say kamala harris's
president would be fantastic because i
can tell you right now republicans would
definitely win in 2024 if kamala was
president yeah but i mean i feel like
they're going to win if biden's
president too because
can you imagine joe biden trying to go
up against trump he didn't do it the
first time he just he what do they call
a lid and then he just hid in his
basement yeah and they were they were
betting on people just hating trump now
you're going to put out a president
who's destroyed the economy who presided
over let's just say that the destruction
of the economy the expansion of a war in
eastern europe the first time since like
world war ii horrible food prices
through the roof inflation through the
roof gas shortages coming yep panic fear
chaos and then they got it they got it
so i actually think kamala harris as bad
as she is it'd probably knock him up a
couple points
i don't know they don't like kamala like
remember when she was yeah when she was
in the primary she was one of the least
popular ones democrats don't like her no
i was a i was a i was a tulsi fella when
she ripped into her during the debates
about i mean she's done
horribly anti-progressive things uh with
with criminal justice in california i
mean it's it's been abysmal she like
bragged about slavery right she she she
bragged about well
previously she got she bragged about now
she's getting called out for it was her
office i believe that kept inmates in
longer to use as cheap labor to fight
wildfires and it's funny when i say that
and people go inmates don't fight
wildfires and i'm like oh ho ho buddy
read the 13th amendment it allows for
slavery with after the conviction of a
crime or something that effect so yeah
that's why they can make no money but
they're even doing labor they give like
a dollar a dollar yeah risk your life in
a wildfire
because you're an inmate yeah and it's
the best thing you can do and she's like
we'll deny their parole and just do it
this way also by the way remember that
the majority of prisoners in america are
also there for non-violent drug offenses
so it's not like they're like sending
just like a rag tag it's not like
suicide squad where they're sending a
bunch of assassins to fight wildfires
it's just like dudes who were caught
selling dime bags in the 80s or they're
in solitary confinement for going in the
capitol on january 6th pre-trial that's
right
yeah a 69 year old cancer patient i love
this they claimed you saw the story
right yeah so the prosecution said that
she was yelling for people to go in the
building and i was like oh wow she was
really
kind of like
like ray apps well where's that guy i
don't
know
you know that they they they bring up
this uh people on the right mention the
69 year old woman with cancer yes i've
been furious about it two months and
so then you hear the argument and
they're like she was encouraging people
to to trespass and all that and i was
like
wow she was encouraging trespassing it's
kind of like the media is it anything
like the uh bear staffers who lied about
having credentials
caused such a ruckus that a democrat
staffer called for emergency services
we're banging on people's doors after
hours and telling people they're gonna
be putting things in there under their
doors is that better or worse no you can
tell me it's the same i don't care it's
certainly at the very least worse than
what someone's accused of doing and the
prosecutor said well you know we
wouldn't get a conviction anyway so
that's a two-tier justice system yeah
that uh that same film crew was outside
my office they targeted my office
capitol police have it on video um but
yeah there's there's no prosecution
happen the office that actually allowed
them to come in is jake austin claus's
office uh and his chief of staff is tim
heisem who is the guy caught on camera
and arrested by capitol police that was
targeting the sign outside my office
but no doj won't prosecute any of it but
yeah they put a 69 year old cancer
patient in jail for two months she
walked she okay she told people to go in
she walked into the capitol i think she
was in there five minutes that's what i
read and then she came back out she was
filming
she said that i like to film these
things yeah like what you post on social
media that everyone should come down and
this is what they do if you go on social
media and you're like everybody should
protest in dc and then everyone shows up
wearing the pink [ __ ] hats and that's
it everyone's fine but you get a couple
hundred of those people to then tear a
fence down and they're gonna claim that
your call for protest was actually a
call for violence that's right that's
what they did
but it's like the media uh uh talking
about all the antifa blm protests and
they were burning cities they burned
washington dc it was on fire it was
mostly peaceful a little bit fiery but
you know i mean everybody's let off
right it's that aerial shot of dc with
the fire everywhere the smoke coming out
all over the place did you guys see
aoc's uh recommendations for how to
protest she has a graphic
did you remember that a while ago do you
remember it's on her graphic that she
recommends heat resistant gloves whoa
yes
it is
heat resistant gloves goggles and a mask
non-descript clothing and cover up any
identifiable tattoos it's like how to be
a terrorist thing uh it was posted
during all the blm and antifa riots
i gotta i gotta i wanna go back to the
biden covered thing because i wanna
point out to everybody that one of the
most uh scariest symptoms of covid is
a loss of your sense of smell we have
this tweet here from thomas massey oh
boy he said sweaty what if he loses his
sense of smell
and it's biden's sniffing children and
women
this could be the end of joe
biden when he can't sniff women and
children he's like just let me again the
other day yeah he was well it's a thing
he loves to do it someone someone posted
there like imagine wearing a mask
getting uh double vaxxed and triple
boosted and then you catch code because
joe biden sniffed you oh no
that's not good not good i had to pull
it up i know i don't want to derail from
the conversation but i was like this is
like
if biden were watching a horror movie
they would it's about a guy who loses a
sense that's what it is
it's just him riding an amtrak into the
sunset
leave me on this amtrak to delaware all
right tim i just texted you aoc's uh
post oh yeah of her protesting safely so
i just sent it to him and maybe he can
give it to you yeah yeah and you guys
can put it up remember that and uh from
what i can tell i haven't confirmed this
independently but i saw a news article
saying that biden has in fact lost his
sense of smell so all over oh boy oh wow
you can fact check it for me you know
look look i got to say
for all the faults of joe biden to take
to to revel in the loss of his one true
joy pleasure it's just it's just
should we have a moment of silence i was
gonna i was gonna try and do this for
him we should pray for
no maybe we should pray for it yeah
exactly
save the children yeah
any child any child listening at the
show was like no
i just i i really do appreciate marjorie
that you're a member of congress making
these jokes it's fantastic well i'm a
normal person right i'm a regular person
that's why a lot of people think i you
know they say terrible things about me
but uh yeah you know what i'll be uh
i'll be honest off the bat um when
i heard we were gonna be on the show
together i just envisioned every liberal
that i follow on twitter my family i'm
like god everyone's gonna hate me and
then part of me was like okay maybe i
need to get sound bites going after her
and then because of you marjorie i had
to watch a 10 minute very unfunny daily
show clip uh it was so long dude it was
so long uh all about you and i was like
this is terrible and then everyone here
was like dude you're gonna love her and
i'm like i don't know and they're like
you're gonna love her and then literally
before the show i was like i love her
so you were making me laugh you were
telling stories you were giving me
advice on my classes i know what you're
glad you're saying right now jamie 10
years ago would be too scared to
actually confront jaime
now jamie 10 years ago would be like if
i go on a show with jamie in 10 years
i'll get cancelled yeah yeah yeah
i would just sadly tweet about it and
then not talk to this jamie face to face
but you know what jamie you know what i
think the deal is i think most americans
we actually agree on more things
than than we realize don't you charm me
with that uh yeah no i agree well and we
were talking about this before the show
which is i love the fact that
the
congresswoman that is talking about that
here is known as one of the most divided
because i say that on stage i do stand
up where there
in my show there are stuff where i make
fun of the left and make fun of the
right and everybody like real people not
twitter personalities everybody laughs
at the same stuff and then you go hey if
we can take that laughter outside and
just assume that you have good
intentions and that i have good
intentions and that if we talk we
probably have some similar values and
different ways to get to it would
probably be fine and then everyone's
like yeah but instead we're just glued
to twitter and facebook and cnn and fox
news and all these corporations that
essentially profit off of us fighting
they do and they and they put us into
sound bites
so you can make anyone seem horrible or
angry or bad in any way if you put them
into sound bites because you can twist
whatever these little bitty sentence or
whatever it is yeah people don't know
you actually went on for three hours
about jewish space lasers if you heard
the whole three hour thing it was it's
so much more it made so much the context
was very stripped out
i know yeah there were poems in it which
was great me as a jew i appreciated it
yeah
and i and i funded them i voted to fund
them yes
i'm actually impressed with the
technology i think it's amazing she was
super proud of that here's the crazy
thing that i see though
i see people posting memes claiming that
you talked about jewish space lasers
which you literally did not do i never
said that phrase right i didn't even
know the phrase until they were writing
articles about me and i was trending on
twitter with the hashtag jewish jewish
space lasers i was like what are they
talking about
but i look at these memes and there are
people who genuinely believe you you
claimed that and it was like dude i did
i was just like because i didn't
research it you see everyone talking
about on twitter and then you see real
verified journalists and you go all
right well that's the new crazy congress
lady who i got to talk about
us having space lasers or whatever then
you read it you were talking about pg e
yeah and investment firms
and it was like
and i mentioned that a rothschild was on
the board
and i didn't even know they were jewish
i would describe it
i would describe it as that's so funny i
didn't know
i would describe the post as just asking
questions conspiracy theory internet
posting like you were very much like
it was it was all question marks yeah it
was like is it possible that this could
have happened i i'll tell you personally
i think it's silly but the fact that
they construed a silly post on facebook
into you claiming jewish people had
space lasers is just the it's it's it
had nothing to do with jewish people it
had everything to do with the technology
that was new that was harnessing the
sun's energy and sending it back to it
to transmitters
uh to create create energy it was just
that's what i was talking about and
that's more like a mexican thing i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding just kidding crazy it canceled
too i don't know or maybe that's what
happened to my forehead
actually burned it with a curling iron
they knew that if they tried to actually
say
here's what it is they find a post from
you
where i think
like
i don't know enough about the
transmission technology i have read
about how they do solar capture and then
they use uh i thought it was really
interesting solar capture energy
transmission to base stations in the u.s
has been stuff that i've read about in
sci-fi and then you uh were asking if it
could be used to start wildfires or
something no no no i was asking i and i
was just asking
like
anytime there's something new right
whenever there's a new invention a new
creation is there a mistake like when
the wright brothers
started to fly how many how many times
did you see like brand new airplanes
people trying it out and they crashed
right i was just asking could there be
like a miscalculation and
and where they're sending it back to
could it miss because our earth rotates
and
things move in space it was like
literally just asking questions that was
it i wasn't i wasn't accusing anyone
especially jewish people i would never
do that
the post is nothing the post is nothing
the post is nothing and so there's no
story unless you reframe it as jewish
space lasers and i think it was in 2018
yeah it was insane let me let me tell
you i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna rag on
this because i know i bring it up a
little bit but it's a good segue when uh
i said this in january
how how are you going to convict people
on january 6 of trespassing if the
police are on video opening doors for
them now obviously the people who broke
glass and are fighting with cops yeah
they're hitting cops of course you get
charged for that right the young turks
did a segment calling saying i had the
stupidest argument ever
and it's like they just literally
strawmanned and misconstrued on purpose
what i was saying
i was right a guy i think his name is
matthew martin was acquitted on all
charges
because the judge saw the video of the
cops fanning people in
now some people were fanned in some
people the doors open aoc said so
she did but this is what this is what we
we see that is what we refer to as the
quote-unquote left is like
they will intentionally misconstrue your
post in a way to smear you because they
know their viewers aren't smart enough
to actually fact check
well they have a purpose in this story
right it's a political purpose they
don't want trump to run for president
again they have to smear him in as much
as possible they have to embarrass him
and everyone that worked for him anyone
that aligns with him because they have
to they want to stop him from running
for president again that's what this is
all about same as the russia hoax they
wanted to impeach them and get them out
and january 6 is another issue so it's
they target anyone
that that defies the their narrative
well also what's so frustrating about it
is look me and you are going to disagree
probably on some trans stuff we're going
to disagree probably on abortion stuff
we're going to disagree
a lot of things right but if
i'm just taking things that you didn't
say or saying things that are out of
context that means i don't have an
argument i would so much rather
talk to someone and find out what we do
have in common and then we can talk
about it so like abortion's a a great
example where
i used to just be no questions asked um
completely pro-choice and then i talked
to conservative friends and i learned
about some of the late term abortions
i'm like i don't love that but one thing
that i will always say and i will
vehemently uh
uh defend is i go hey
if we're restricting abortion rights
which a lot of the stuff i don't agree
on maybe we should also talk about more
sex education or more access to
contraceptives and i feel like with
every political issue there are
these middle grounds where it's like
okay if i give you that like how if the
goal is just here's the issue the right
is offering nothing but compromise it is
objectively true
the overturning of roe v wade is a
conservative compromise
uh well let me ask you right
do you think abortion should be banned
totally
i am
unapologetically i believe in life at
conception i do i think that and i'll
tell you because i'm a mom i have three
kids
and there's nothing that i could ever do
in my life even if i became president
even if i created world peace i there's
nothing i could do in my life that would
be greater than being a mom because i
love my kids that much and it's i
consider it a true blessing
so and i don't think anyone is a mistake
i do not i believe that every single
person
that god uh has a plan for them even if
they're unwanted even if they came out
of a horrible rape or something i just i
truly believe that
there's a reason for them i want to
separate this into two uh distinct
questions in the same area right there
is the political implementation of a ban
versus the personal feeling there should
be right do you personally feel abortion
is wrong and shouldn't be allowed yes
that's how i personally feel politically
do you think in the entire nation there
should be a nationwide ban on abortion
in every state at the federal level if i
had to vote on that yes i would vote on
that so
here's the issue but let me add to it i
do not think our government is serving
our the american people and we we should
do more for women we should do more for
orphans we should do more to help we
should help people and we don't do that
we send our monies overseas to foreign
countries we we build schools and walls
and and roads in foreign countries we
fund foreign wars but we do nothing we
do nothing to incentivize families flint
michigan needed water pipes for a long
time but here's my point what the
republicans ended up doing is allowing
the states to decide if they have
abortion or not
and the left is acting like i know the
supreme court did that i'm sorry yeah
the supreme court ruled
they gave the right back to the states
gave it back to the states and now you
have red states saying you know uh many
red states saying we're putting limits
on abortion and blue states that's a
compromised position the republicans
didn't come out and the supreme court i
should say could have ruled abortion was
completely illegal under the 14th
amendment the supreme court six to three
of conservative justices could have said
the 14th amendment guarantees equal
rights under the law and we hereby
recognize life at conception as a simple
moral principle they could have said
that they didn't
they went halfway and said we shouldn't
decide on this it's up to you guys to
figure out the last thing they they gave
it back to the states to decide because
really our federal government has grown
way too big i mean you could look at
this in so many different issues and
avenues but giving it back to the states
actually gives people more control it
really does thanks for checking out this
clip from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you